You know, usually when we talk about a dystopian future where language is controlled, we kind of go straight to George Orwell. We think of 1984 and the concept of new speak, like this idea of language being deliberately
narrowed by some authoritarian regime until nobody can even express an unapproved thought.
Right. It's the classic sci-fi trope. A conscious, malicious plot to shrink the human mind by literally shrinking the vocabulary available to it.
Exactly. But we are doing a deep dive today into a brand new paper. And it turns out the way our language is actually shrinking is entirely different. It's not a conspiracy. There's no dictator sitting in a volcano lair crossing out words in a dictionary.
No, it is actually a much duller and frankly much more fascinating mechanism. What we are looking at is a side effect of how large language models or LLMs actually work under the hood. These models are fundamentally trained to produce the statistically most
likely continuation of a sentence, which means by sheer mechanical design, they pull all writing toward the dead Senate of the Bill Kirsch. Nobody plotted this. It is just happening at scale right now. Every single time
someone uses AI to polish a cover letter or write an email.
I really want to visualize this for a second because it's such a subtle shift. It's like putting a heavy beauty filter on a photo. It smooths out all the wrinkles. It fixes the lighting. It makes everything look conventionally better according to some invisible algorithm. But if you crank
that filter high enough, you don't just lose the blemishes. You lose the person's actual face.
That's a really good way to put it.
And that is the core of our mission today. We're looking at a landmark August 2026 paper published in Nature Human Behavior by Serati and a massive team of researchers. We are also bringing in five foundational papers to give us the history. And the
single profound question we're trying to answer is this. When you ask an AI model to polish your writing, it keeps what you meant. But does it keep who you are?
And as this new paper proves, the answer is no, not entirely. And for the first time, we actually have the tools to measure exactly how much of you goes missing. But to really grasp why this matters, we have to rewind a bit. We need to step back to a foundational paper
by Kaczynski from 2013. Because without this context, the 2026 paper doesn't really have the same stakes. Kaczynski proved that our ordinary everyday digital traces, like our subtle language choices, the words we favor, even our
Facebook likes, they genuinely encode highly sensitive private attributes. We're talking about sexual orientation, political views, personality types. Our language is quite literally a biometric fingerprint.
And this is exactly where it gets so tense. Talk about a double edged sword. Because for over a decade, that Kaczynski finding was treated as this massive, terrifying privacy threat. It was the thing we all needed to defend against. The idea that some mega corporation could read my casual tweets and instantly build a
psychological profile to sell me things or worse. Oh, yeah, absolutely. But now this new Cerati paper treats the erosion of this exact same signal as a profound cultural loss. It's a really complex tension. But before we get to the philosophy of whether losing our fingerprint is good
or bad, let's look at the real world. If our words are our fingerprints, what actually happened to the internet when ChatGPT launched in November 2022?
So the researchers wanted to know exactly that. They asked, is this homogenization actually happening out in the wild? To find out, they tracked the monthly variance in writing complexity from January 2018 all the way to November
2024. And they didn't just look at one corner of the internet. They analyzed over 880,000 texts across three completely distinct spaces.
That's a massive data set.
It's huge. You have creative writing from Reddit.
Okay.
Localized community journalism from Catch News.
Mm-hmm.
And incredibly dense academic computer science abstracts from Archive.
That is a really smart cross-section. You've got the highly technical, the hyperlocal, and the wildly informal. And to figure out what was human and what was AI, they used an AI detection tool called binoculars. So when they mapped this out, did the
timeline actually line up? Did everything just universally get blander? The day chat GPT dropped?
It did get blander, but the client tells a much more nuanced story about how humans actually adopt technology. Let's look at the RQ for a computer science abstracts first. They found a massive sustained decline in the variance of writing complexity immediately
after ChatGPT's launch. It just dropped. Wow. And statistically, they're able to prove that the spike in AI usage directly predicted this drop in linguistic diversity, almost like a shadow, following it with a lag of about five months.
Five months actually makes perfect sense for academia. I mean, you draft a paper, you polish it with AI, it goes through peer review, and then it gets posted. The pipeline takes time. I imagine that timeline looks very different for a place like Reddit, where you have everyday people writing creative stories, not just early adopter tech researchers.
Exactly. Reddit also saw a massive sustained decline in linguistic diversity. The drop was undeniable. But the lag between AI becoming available and the language actually flattening out was much longer. Yeah. It was 20 months.
20 months.
Yeah.
So it took almost two years for the blindness to really infect Reddit.
Right. And the researchers attribute this to diffusion speed. Computer science researchers on ArcCiv are early adopters. They saw the tool and integrated it into their workflow instantly.
Naturally.
But Reddit is a massive, broad, general population. It took longer for the average user to figure out how to use AI to help them write creative stories. But once that adoption hit critical mass, the diversity plummeted just the same.
That leaves the journalist at Patch News. How did local news fare?
Patch News is the outlier, and we really need to state this plainly. There was a sharp, immediate plummet in variance right when ChatGPT launched. However, the statistical tests show that we cannot definitively say AI usage predicted that drop. Yeah, the tests just
weren't significant. The Granger causality test was like 0.114. It's entirely possible that the drop there was driven by human editorial guidelines or a rigid house style pushing back against AI rather than the
AI itself writing the articles.
OK, I'm glad you brought that up because I have to play the skeptic here. If I'm looking at the Internet in 2023 and 2024, the world is a chaotic mess. We're coming out of a global pandemic. There are massive cultural shifts happening everywhere. Sure. Correlation isn't causation.
How do we know the A.I. actually caused the homogenization on red in arcs of maybe human culture just globally shifted toward a less diverse, safer linguistic style?
It's a completely valid critique, and it's exactly why the researchers knew they couldn't just rely on observing the wild Internet to prove the A.I. was the culprit. They had to put it in a vacuum. They had to run a controlled experiment.
Ah, so they needed a control group uncontaminated by 2023 culture.
Exactly. They went back and gathered 1,000 human-authored texts from Reddit and ArcSieve that were written before ChatGPT even existed. They essentially froze that human writing in amber. Then they had three different models.
GPT 3.5, Lama 370B, and Gemini Pro polished these texts.
And what did they tell the AI to do? Because if you say, you know, rewrite this in a corporate voice, obviously it's going to homogenize it.
That's the brilliance of the design. The prompts were incredibly innocuous. Twelve neutral prompts. Things like rephrase, improve clarity, smooth, improve readability. It's
really basic stuff.
Crucially, nobody asked the AI to change the author's voice or style. They just asked for a chromatical polish.
Just fix the syntax. Make it sound a little tighter. And what happened?
The result, and this is the crux of the whole paper, meaning survives but style does not. They mapped the semantics of the text, essentially checking if the ideas remain intact. And 87% of the text kept a cosine similarity above 0.95 with the original.
Which means they were virtually identical in meaning.
Exactly. The models didn't change the story. But the variance in writing complexity... The uniqueness of the pros. It plummeted by 21 to 50 percent across the data sets and models. It was all statistically significant
percent. That is staggering.
The strongest single case was Lama three working on the Reddit posts. It literally halved the variance from point zeros zero nine one down to point zero zero four five. It took all these distinct, weird,
unique human voices and squeezed them into a box half the size.
So if you are a user and you only check to see if the model changed what you said, the AI passes with flying colors, you read it and think, yep, that's exactly what I meant to say. It just sounds better. The loss is happening in a dimension nobody is auditing. The texture, the rhythm, the individuality, that's what quietly gets erased.
If we pull back and connect this to the broader literature, it perfectly mirrors the findings of two other major papers from 2024, Papakumar and Doshi. Papakumar found that writing with a model reduced diversity across authors,
and Doshi ran an amazing experiment where writers used AI to help them brainstorm and write short stories.
Let me guess. The stories were technically better, but structurally identical.
You nailed it. Independent judges rated the AI-assisted stories as better written, more enjoyable, and more creative. But, and this is the kicker, when you looked at the stories collectively... They were all far more similar to each other than the ones written
entirely by humans. Doshi calls it a social dilemma.
A social dilemma. I see. Because for me, as an individual, sitting at my laptop clicking improve readability on an email is a totally rational choice. I get a clear benefit. My boss thinks I sound more professional. But collectively, when millions of us make that identical rational choice, the entire
ecosystem becomes identical. And the crazy thing is you can't see that collective cultural loss from inside your own Google Doc. You just think you wrote a great email.
Precisely. Which naturally pushes us to the next big question the Cerati team asked. If we're all writing a bit more alike, what is the actual measurable cost of that?
Right. Who really cares if we're all a bit more polished? Does it actually hurt anyone?
The researchers wanted to know if we can still read a person's underlying traits off their prose once the AI has touched it. Remember Kaczynski's digital fingerprints? They gathered data sets where they had both the original texts and independently verified real-world
psychological data about the authors.
Like what kind of data?
We're talking big five personality traits, moral foundations, empathy levels, political affiliation, age, gender. They trained AI classifiers to predict these traits based on the original human writing. Then they fed the AI polished versions of those exact same
texts into the classifiers to see if the humans were still visible.
Let me guess. The classifier suddenly couldn't see the humans anymore. The fingerprint was gone.
They lost a significant amount of vision. The predictive power fell across every single trait they tested. An absolute drop in F1 score of about 6% on average. Age was hit the absolute hardest, falling from 0.351 to 0.260. Now,
we have to be scientifically honest here. The performance of these classifiers does stay above a random guessing baseline. The signal is degraded heavily, but it is not completely destroyed.
Okay, so the AI is just acting like a blur tool. It's taking all of our sharp edges and blurring us into a neutral, gray, perfectly average blob.
No. And this is the absolute bombshell of the paper. This is the part that we need to give the most air to. Because it elevates it from a simple complaint about AI making things bland to something much more profound. The damage is not random noise. It has a direction. The AI isn't pushing
everyone toward a neutral center-of-the-road average. It is actively rewriting us toward one highly specific imagined author.
What do you mean? It has a directional bias. It's picking a persona.
A massive one. When classifiers look at the AI rewritten text... They systematically read the author as older, and that was a large effect, a Cohen's D of 1.09. They read the author as more politically liberal, and this is crucial. It does this
even when the original human author was a registered Republican. Oh, wow. The classifiers also read the AI text as more male, less empathetic, and highly moralistic.
Wait, hold on. Older, male, liberal? moralizing and unemotional like whose voice is that even why on earth would a machine that is trained on the entire chaotic diverse internet default to that specific guy
To understand why, we have to look at how these models were built and who was building them. The authors connect this to documented biases in the models themselves. And we can look at two papers from 2025 to see how damaging this default can be. Agarwal studied Indian and American writers using AI.
The AI didn't just correct the grammar of the Indian writers, it actively pulled them toward Western American norms.
Really?
It even went so far as to swap out their cultural, food, and festival references for Western ones. It helped them less and required more edits.
Wow. It's literally rewriting culture. It's taking a localized human experience and paving over it with a Western default.
Yes. And Wang showed a similar failure mode. When researchers try to use LLMs to simulate different demographic groups, the models misportray and flatten those identities. They collapse all the beautiful within group variation so that an entire
demographic is represented by a single caricatured voice. So whether the AI is speaking for a group or polishing an individual's writing, the statistical pull toward the mode erases internal variety. Two literatures, two methods, one failure mode.
So we aren't just losing our fingerprints. We are having someone else's fingerprints painted over ours. But how is the AI actually doing this mechanically? If I tell it to just fix my grammar, how does it manage to erase my gender or my personality in sentence level? Is it just throwing a blanket of corporate jargon over
everything?
The researchers went down to the sociolinguistic level to figure this out. They used established psychological dictionaries like LIWC and the Moral Foundations Dictionary to test which specific word links survive a rewrite and which don't. And what they found is selective
erosion. The AI doesn't add noise across the board. It acts almost like a surgeon, removing some identity markers while leaving others perfectly intact.
Give me an example of the surgery. What gets cut?
Well, first they replicated classic findings in the original texts, like male authors use fewer social words, extraversion tracks with positive emotion words. But in the rewrites, the strong statistically solid link between the author's gender and the use of negative emotion
words, which was super clear in the original, it's essentially gone after rewriting. Just
totally gone.
The PI view went from .001 up to .230. The connection between extroversion and the use of pronouns. Weak and below significance. Age and future focus words. Gone.
And what survives the cut? What does it let you keep?
The link between neuroticism and negative emotion words survives completely intact. The link between the moral concept of purity and religion-related words survives. It depends entirely on the specific trait and the words carrying it. The AI is
systematically dismantling some cue to trait links based on how it was tuned, but it leaves other linguistic habits standing.
Okay, let's unpack this for the real world because it's easy to get lost in the theory. If I'm not a sociolinguist, if I'm just a person going to work, why should I care that my extroversion pronouns are missing from my polished email? What is the actual harm here?
The authors identify four major areas where this bites hard. Let's start with clinical and mental health work. For years, therapists and diagnostic tools have looked for subtle linguistic signals. Changes in pronoun, use slight shifts in sentiment to detect cognitive decline, depression,
or even suicidal ideation.
Oh, man. So if a patient is struggling, but they're using an AI assistant to write their journal entries or their emails to their doctor, those vital desperate signals are being literally paved over by a helpful AI grammar check. You sound perfectly fine and emotionally
regulated right up until you aren't.
Precisely. The tool designed to help you communicate actually hides your distress. The second major area is hiring and equity. Imagine an applicant tracking system or just a tired hiring manager assessing hundreds of cover letters.
Right. If you have an applicant who is distinct, neurodivergent or has a culturally unique writing style. Exactly. If they don't match the implicit house style that AI has trained us all to expect, they might get penalized. They get judged as unprofessional just because
they didn't run their passion through the Lama 3 beauty filter. It becomes an equity issue disguised as a style issue.
Exactly. You are punished for being authentic. Third is marketing and personalization. The whole industry assumes that linguistic variation exists so you can segment audiences and personalize messaging. But you cannot personalize your message to a completely
homogenized, identical audience.
If everyone talks like a Silicon Valley manager, how do you sell them different shoes?
Exactly. And fourth, the social sciences themselves. For a century, fields like psychology, sociology, and linguistics have used language as a primary window into humanity. They study our words to understand who we are. That window is
quietly, rapidly fogging up. The very instruments researchers use to study human behavior implicitly assume that nobody ran the text through a machine learning model first, which, as we saw in the Art6 corpus, isn't true anymore.
We do need to be fair, though, and look at the honest limits of this research. It's a massive paper, but it's not perfect. The first part, study one, looking at Reddit and Oryx was purely observational. It's not a clean lab experiment, so there's always going to be noise in that data. Yeah. And the binoculars
tool they use to detect the AI writing, it's tuned for high precision, which means it only flags things it is absolutely sure about. It actually undercounts lightly edited hybrid human AI text. And we already mentioned the news corpus didn't show a
predictive relationship at all.
Which is an important limit. But the authors argue that undercounting actually makes their estimates conservative rather than inflated. If the tool is missing the lightly edited text, the real homogenization happening out there is likely even worse than what they measured.
Fair point. But also, we have to acknowledge the trait classifiers they use to predict age and politics. They are imperfect instruments to begin with. Human identity is incredibly complex, and a machine learning classifier guessing your political affiliation from a single paragraph is never
going to be flawlessly accurate.
True, the baseline isn't perfect, but it's the relative drop in their accuracy that tells the story. The AI undeniably makes them worse at their job. So if we pull the thread through all of this, Kaczynski proved back in 2013 that language carries our identity.
It's our fingerprint. Padma Kumar, Doshi Agarwal, and Wang. They each found a piece of the homogenization effect in a lab, a domain, or a practice, showing how AI pulls us to the center and erases cultural nuance.
And now Serati has proven the immense terrifying scale of this. Hundreds of thousands of real documents starting the very day ChatGPT shipped. It survives every robustness check they threw at it and its cost is not aesthetic.
Yes. Language has been for as long as anyone who studied people, the richest available signal about who they are. And we are running an unplanned global experiment on attenuating it one polished email at a time. We're losing a measurement instrument.
OK, I have to play devil's advocate here. I hear the cultural loss. I hear the fogging of the social science window. But isn't this also a massive privacy win? Think back to Kaczynski. We're terrified of that fingerprint being readable. For a century, human editors and style
guides have homogenized writing for publication anyway. The effects here, while real, still left the classifiers beating a random guess. So if using ChatGPT makes me just a little bit harder for a mega corporation to profile, track, and target with
hyper-specific ads, I'm calling that a feature, not a bug. If I can hide in the herd, I want to hide in the herd.
It's a genuinely compelling argument. And the Cerati paper even concedes that these cues are double edged and weakening them reduces surveillance and discrimination risks. But I would push back hard against calling it a true privacy win. And it all comes back to that
directional bias finding. It would be a privacy feature if the AI made you invisible.
Right.
If it just blurred you into static or a perfectly neutral average. But it doesn't do that. It averages you into an older, liberal, unemotional, moralizing man. You aren't achieving true privacy. You're just wearing a cultural costume that you didn't consent to put on, you are trading
surveillance for erasure.
A cultural costume? Wow. Trading surveillance for erasure. That is an incredibly heavy trade-off. I mean, we're fixing our grammar. We're getting the promotion, hiding from the algorithm, but at the cost of painting over our own fingerprints with someone else's. It really makes you think about the
friction we used to have in writing and what that friction actually produced. It produced us. Next time you click improve readability on an email, ask yourself, Are you just fixing your grammar or are you quietly letting the machine decide who you get to be today?